troisième nuit blanche célébrée à saint
quentin en yvelines à elancourt samedi
soir les artistes ont investi le
quartier historique 17 mar dans la salle
obscure du prisme julie dumont pastis
yen a présenté ses trois courts métrages
et le mieux il est toujours 9 g dominé
savez plusieurs nuits blanches participe
enfin c'est avec moi c'est un travail
très polyvalent je travaille le dessin
sous toutes ses formes
donc ça va du film d'animation jusqu'à
la performance voilà je suis dans le
croquis rapides vraiment dans la matière
je cherche à piéger l'instant décisif
autre instant autre lieu les élèves de
l'école municipale de danse d'elancourt
ont réchauffé l'atmosphère de la
médiathèque prennent un équipier
le public a été conquis et c'est très
bien organisé il ya beaucoup de monde ce
qui est intéressant
les participants eux mêmes sont sont
dynamiques sont présents ils sont
motivés c'est super le moment clé de la
nuit la représentation de la pièce
chorégraphique les langues de jean
claude gallotta
pour l'occasion le chorégraphe fait
appel aux élans courtois sur scène les
amateurs ont séduit le professionnel moi
j'ai accepté tout de suite le projet
puisque je sais que pour l'avoir
anticipée je sais aussi le travail qu'on
peut faire avec eux et l'énergie qu'ils
peuvent y mettre le sentiment l' envie
de découvrir de partager en le sens là
derrière moi c'est formidable c'est une
occasion inouïe de rencontrer d'autres
habitants que ça fait du lien social que
ce fait une animation dans le quartier
en plus on a la chance d'être avec un
chorégraphe hyper connus hiver
formidable donc je pense que c'est une
chance à saisir à cet été avait renoncé
aussi un musée on a pris du plaisir
et puis on voit aussi les autres groupes
on voit qu'ils sont arrivés à faire des
choses superbes et on pensait pas
pouvoir faire ça au départ le plaisir
aura duré jusqu'au bout de la nuit
même la pluie n'a pu freiner les 1500
noctambules